[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans
parlement hebdo une semaine un peu
particulière à l'assemblée et au sénat
marquée par la mort de jacques chirac ce
jeudi 26 septembre dès l'annoncé de son
décès l'assemblée nationale a interrompu
les travaux en séance publique pour
observer une minute de silence en
hommage à l'ancien président de la
république
au sénat les parlementaires ont eux
aussi rendu hommage à jacques chirac
dans les mystiques d hommage spontané et
un hommage solennel en début
d'après-midi dans un silence
impressionnant
et des sénateurs de tous bords ont
évoqué le souvenir de l'ancien président
de la république à notre micro
écoutez ses réactions ce qui disparaît
c'est une manière de faire de la
politique d'une manière de proximité de
préaux d'école plus que de réseaux
sociaux de capacité à se parler à se
regarder à se comprendre à dire les
choses à ne pas être d'accord mais à
s'aimer à se tolérer à se respecter
chirac c'est la république chirac c'est
la nation c'est la laïcité c'est la
notion de rassemblement très au delà des
clivages politiques
est ce que ça existe encore c'est
finalement dans le quinquennat et le
septennat de jacques chirac
qu'effectivement le virage de
préoccupation et d'enjeux
environnementaux a été pris est-ce
qu'ils étaient jusqu'à être écolo on
entend aujourd'hui je pense que voilà
c'est j'aurais dit c'est là où le virage
ses prix la transition s'est mise en
marche bon moi je souhaite rendre
hommage à un homme politique a marqué
l'histoire de france avec elle j'avais
bien des désaccords même si je ne suis
pas de la génération moi je me suis
engagé en 2005 au moment du cpe
mais il ya du respect voilà il y aurait
beaucoup de choses à dire mais moi je
retiendrai aujourd'hui la garnir ac le
non à la guerre d'irak était
profondément qu'à marquer ma génération
sa déambulation dans les rues de
jérusalem en 96 qui ont aussi marqué
fortement sa politique internationale
la maison brûle en 2002 on parle
beaucoup de des questions climatiques en
ce moment donc voilà je rends hommage et
respect condoléances à ses proches à ses
amis à sa famille et à l'assemblée
émotions tout aussi vive quelle que soit
l'étiquette politique chacun avait un
sentiment à partager sur jacques chirac
jacques chirac c'était une personnalité
et 6
vous me permettez cette familiarité et
c'était une gueule une figure une
démarche une allure je trouve qu'il
avait une présence au fond et on le
voyait bien dans les réunions
internationales où la présence physique
comme intellectuel est absolument
indispensable et chirac incarner sa très
très bien il était ce là il était la
france quand ils étaient quelque part
j'avais comme caractéristique d'aimer
les gens et
de vivre sinon milieu d'eux au moins de
chercher à les comprendre en permanence
et il y avait de la proximité c'est
jacques chirac
je pense qu'il y avait un respect de la
république des principes de la
république et d'une certaine vision de
la france y compris y compris sociales
qui ont fait pas un président de droite
comme les autres philippe berta bonjour
bonjour vous êtes député modem du garon
var parcourir avec vous la semaine
parlementaire
mais d'abord et bien votre réaction
personnelle sur la mort de jacques
chirac quelle chirac retenez vous vous
retenez bien l'homme proche des gens
l'homme qui dit non à la guerre en irak
l'homme visionnaire sur le climat un peu
tout ça oui ces problèmes un peu tout ça
c'était un petit peu difficile de
devenir en 1e position pour cet hommage
parce que beaucoup beaucoup de choses
ont été dites de façon très émouvante
je revois la jupe et hier soir c'était
c'était des moments forts je crois
qu'ils ont on va mettre d'abord l'homme
il a réussi à tisser ce lien humain avec
avec chacun d'entre nous une espèce de
de paternalisme des filiations donc on
peut on perd quelque part un espèce de
papa qui a marqué une partie de notre
vie et je me souviens je croisais qu'une
fois pour être sincère dans un institut
de recherche à montpellier est mon
on m de l'époque m'avait dit tu verras
quand il va te serrer la main il va se
passer quelque chose et c'est pas
d'élection il s'est passé quelque chose
et c'était c'était étonnant cette
relation à l'autre cette capacité
d'entraînement bien sûr qui s'est passé
quelque chose c'était pas anodin et
après bien sûr on peut décliner l'homme
dans toutes ses facettes d'abord c'est
l'histoire qui jugera mais moi je
retiens l'européen et c'est important je
retiens le rempart le repas républicain
contre contre les extrêmes je retiens
effectivement cette image c'est une
stature internationale
cette façon de se lever par
l'intermédiaire de de villepin sur sur
l'irak où on sait ô combien il avait
raison et vous de s'entraîner est ce
qu'il incarnait pour vous une époque
révolue
une époque politique révolue une
certaine manière de faire de la
politique qui n'existe plus aujourd'hui
déjà il faut reprendre au parcours même
il d'un côté balzacien c'est un peu
rastignac qui vient de sakho reste
profonde qui monte qui monte à paris je
vais conquérir paris il y en a d'autres
à aujourd'hui
oui je veux courir
je vais conquérir l'état oui mais il
traduisait bien sa génération est
probablement la mienne c'est à dire
c'est ses racines rurales est donc cet
attachement à la terre cet attachement à
l'environnement bien sûr et j'espère que
ce n'est pas révolu c'est important je
pense que c'est ce qui nous a été un
petit peu reproché c'est ce qui nous
manque peut-être un peu aujourd'hui
c'est ce contact cette chaleur humaine
être en permanence sur le terrain
écouter les gens il a il a été un
remarquable et c'est un exemple pour sa
vie emmanuel macron à d'ailleurs dit
nous perdons un homme d'état que nous
aimions autant qu'il nous aimait c'est
drôle aussi le fait que jacques chirac
n'a pas été si populaire quand il était
président de la république mais il ya
tout de même toujours cette postérité
bien pour les pour les hommes politiques
quand il n'exerce plus oui c'est très
difficile d'être populaire quand vous
êtes la gouvernance parce que forcément
vous êtes l'objet d'attaqués puis si
gouverner c'est prend c'est faire des
choix à faire des choix c'est forcément
bien avoir des gens qui vont être en
contre on vit ça au quotidien
mais moi je suis effectivement
impressionné par cette image
a posteriori pas poste vie politique où
je n'entends plus d'avis négatifs vous
avez raison alors je sais pas si c'est
si c'est le cas de tous les présidents
de république mais bon c'est cette
capacité d'oubli qui fait qu'on qu'on
regarde que les points positifs et
heureusement qu'il a été ainsi alors
philippe berta on va refaire à présent
le film de la semaine c'est le principe
de cette émission va d'abord vous
présenter si vous voulez bien en
quelques traits de plume
vous êtes né à besançon dans le doubs
vous êtes un jeune député élu en 2017 et
vous êtes un peu bioman si je puis dire
généticiens biologistes moléculaires de
formation vous avez fait partie des
chercheurs qui ont découvert le gène de
la détermination sexuelle masculine
passer par le cnrs l'inserm ou encore
l'université de montpellier notamment
vous allez créer un incubateur yoyotech
vous êtes enseignant
vous aimez transmettre innover si bien
que vous vous investissez dans le
lancement de start up
en deux mots philippe berta pourquoi le
scientifique que vous êtes at il choisi
la politique
il a choisi la politique parce qu'il
avait envie de faire et pour faire un
moment donné alors tout dépend la
dimension du
j'allais dire de la taille de votre
mégalomanie quand vous les faire moi
j'ai rêvé de un jour de participer à la
construction d'un institut de génétique
humaine parce que avec le professeur de
maille à l'époque je sentais à quel
point dans la fin des années 80 ça
allait être une science qui allait
envahir notre vie explosé et qui change
réels définitivement il n'a pas fini de
le faire la face des choses et un moment
donné si vous voulez créer cette échelle
là eh bien il vous faut l'appui du
politique
et puis vous apercevez que que dans le
domaine des sciences et techniques si je
peux me permettre
on a quand même déjà une faiblesse du
culturel au niveau du pays mais qui se
traduit aussi par une faiblesse
culturelle au niveau des politiques
je suis pourquoi pas y aller liberta on
va entendre ce que vous avez à dire sur
le projet de loi de bioéthique
vous êtes l'un des rapporteurs spéciaux
de ce texte examiné depuis le début de
la semaine à l'assemblée nationale
[Musique]
les députés sont entrés dans le vif du
sujet en débattant de l'article 1 qui
ouvre la pma à toutes les femmes
la discussion et l'on compte tenu du
nombre d'amendements déposés sur le
sujet mari la bat
c'est la mesure la plus attendue du
texte une promesse de campagne
d'emmanuel macron l'ouverture de la pma
à toutes les femmes le projet de loi
bioéthique est une chance et même un
privilège pour notre pays
sur ces questions comme sur tant
d'autres la france est regardée la voix
de la france est écouté seuls les
républicains se sont invariablement
opposé à l'article
il y aura un effet domino également du
passage de la pma vers la gpa pourquoi
parce que la situation est la même
il s'agit de deux catégories de couples
qui sont confrontés dans les deux cas la
même réalité la pma pour toutes
concernent aussi les femmes célibataires
une extension qui a laissé apparaître
des divergences au sein même de la
majorité le questionnement que je vous
soumets il est très simple et tout en
droit de proposer un enfant
d'institutionnaliser un environnement
familial qui ne prend pas en compte la
figure paternelle qui met de côté
délibérément tout ce qui a trait au
masculin
enfin les députés se sont affrontés sur
la pma post mortem c'est vraiment une
situation us on dirait une femme veuve
votre projet parental s'est arrêtée on
va vous avez la possibilité de donner
vos embryons ou de les détruire
mais dans le même temps vous conserver
la possibilité de faire une amp avec
tiers donneur ce serait une nouvelle
ligne rouge de franchie par ce que
symboliquement et je dis bien
symboliquement ce qui est en jeu ça
reviendrait à faire engendrer à mort
près de 600 amendements ont été étudiées
pour le seul article 1er dans les jours
qui viennent
les députés devront désormais débattre
de la filiation des enfants de couples
de femmes nées par pma ou encore de la
levée de l'anonymat des donneurs de
gamètes
alors philippe berthe en séance le débat
est long il ya beaucoup d'amendements
chacun s'exprime
quitte à peut projeter son histoire
personnelle cependant dans les débats
est ce que pour vous qui êtes donc
rapporteur spécial sur ce texte
est ce que pour vous c'est une loi de
bioéthique comme une autre où c'est plus
une loi sociétale dans la mesure où l
ombre de nouveaux droits
c'est un peu toute la difficulté de
cette loi parce que vous m'avez définit
comme co rapporteurs c'est vrai mais je
suis pas encore réellement intervenus
puisque moi je suis sur les aspects
scientifiques on a vraiment une loi
qu'il ferait dichotomie on à la sasp et
sociétaux c'est ce qui nous anime
actuellement qui nous prennent beaucoup
beaucoup de temps puisque nous sommes
toujours sur l'article 2 1 après une
semaine de débats monopolise les débats
sermonné plus un petit peu le débat puis
vous avez des aspects scientifiques et
et je moi je ne viendront plus tard
viendront plus tard mais il faut faire
le lien entre les deux parce que parce
que il faut une fois à servir la
technique qu'elle n'aille pas nous
permettre de faire des choses que que
que la morale ou l'éthique réprouve donc
c'est vraiment passionnant pour moi
d'être parlementaire à ce moment là les
lois de bioéthique je les suis moi
j'avais rencontré claude huriez à
l'époque et caetera et de se retrouver
au coeur au coeur de ce questionnement
mais c'est très compliqué parce que mais
très intéressant parce que pour une fois
ya plein d'histoires de clivages
politiques
ce sont vous l'avez dit êtes étonnés
parce qu'on retrouve pas les clivages
qui avait pu avoir par exemple avec le
mariage pour tous tout le monde
craignait bien sûr de voir ressurgir et
bien toutes ces fractures non on a
évolué c'est plutôt de bonne nouvelle
parce que ça veut dire qu'on est capable
temps en temps de d'enlever ce costume
je suis opposant donc je m'oppose je
suis la majorité donc j'accepte noms sur
ces sociétés cessé de sylla il faut
vraiment une autre posture elle est
prise par un certain nombre de députés
moi je je je veux souligner ici par
exemple député minot puisqu'il en plus
lui et dans un coup politique un peu
complexe pour soutenir ce texte qui a
pris ces risques qui les assume et
d'ailleurs tiens et si j'ai bien compris
en les républicains et aujourd'hui il
est même menacée ce qui était juste
incroyable dans une démocratie où 21e
siècle comme un autre et justement vous
dites que vous avez dit beaucoup de
députés ont tendance à projeter un peu
la leur vie personnelle s'est excusé
normal législateur il a peut-être pas à
faire c'est pas normal c'est difficile à
éviter
moi non je pense que maintenant nous
savons qu'il ya eu des enfants pma ne
savons qui est issu d'un mur grâce au
débat dans le débat des musiques c'est
ce que c'est normal qu'un si je suis pas
bien sûr je revois ce députés en
commission qui verse une larme enfin je
pense qu'il ya non il faut tenter par
tous les moyens d'enlever ce costume là
c'est pas facile moi je moi même je
pourrais éventuellement rentrer par ce
biais là dans ce texte
est ce dire non je regarde l'intérêt
général c'est moi j'essaie cette
difficulté par exemple sur la recherche
des origines qui me pose problème parce
qu on utilise des outils aujourd'hui qui
sont des outils à problèmes pour ce
faire je comprends bien ce souhait mais
d'un autre côté je sais aussi à quoi ça
mène comme travers donc qu elle n était
gêné par le test de base de données
outre atlantique auquel beaucoup d'entre
nous contre la loi d'ailleurs faisait
interpellent et qui qui sont très
questionnable et qui doit d'ailleurs
nous nous amener à penser un dispositif
à la française liberta vous avez dit que
vous vous occupez plutôt des aspects
scientifiques de ce projet de loi est ce
que vous pensez que le législateur est
suffisamment armée pour légiférer sur
ces sujets ces sujets scientifiques de
pointe
c'est pas facile pour des députés qui
peuvent être un peu tout terrain et pas
forcément spécialiste de ce sujet c'est
vrai que sur un texte comme ça encore
plus que d'habitude
il ya vraiment je pense qu'il y aura
vraiment les députés qui ont vécu le
travail de commission quand vécu d'abord
la mission l'hiver dernier qui ont vécu
la mission extraordinaire qui a été mise
en place au cours du mois d'août et donc
qui sont là depuis maintenant plus d'un
mois ne travailler que sur ce thème qui
ne sont pas forcément des scientifiques
du tout au départ où les médecins et qui
eux ont pu réfléchir échanger on a
beaucoup de discussion of aussi en
dehors des moments de débats jean nevers
encore je vois très bien avec un député
fort tard cette nuit
et ces gens là ont acquis une
connaissance franchement ce jour des
gens
jean brillant je n'ai pas eu de souci
là-dessus alors c'est plus difficile
pour ceux qui arrivent parce qu'ils
ressentent à 0 ils ont pas ce que
j'appellerais un très joli ce pack
grande qui s'est construit
progressivement on a une question
importante pour vous vous allez défendre
un amendement en séance sur une question
qui est particulière sur lequel vous
êtes travail et celle du diagnostic
préimplantatoire
c'est très technique mais en gros ça
permet d'éviter un couple qui a recours
à une pma de transmettre un deuxième
enfant une la maladie que le premier a
eu c'est bien ça est ce que vous
regrettez la manière dont ce diagnostic
qui offre une solution thérapeutique à
des parents est menée alors déjà ce que
je regrette c'est qu'on soit si lent
dans ce pays à appliquer les découvertes
scientifiques cessera pas une surprise
si je vous dis ça par rapport à d'autres
pays et sur le dpi a eu des découvertes
ailleurs qu'on applique dansant sur le
dpi et j'essaie de replacer expliqué le
dpi c'est un diagnostic préimplantatoire
ça concerne 4 % des procréations
médicalement assistées c'est à dire ce
sont des pros création qui se font par
fécondation in vitro jeu mais l'ovocyte
le spermatozoïde dans une boîte de pétri
et je produis un embryon que je
réimplante mais dans 4 % des cas nous
savons en tout cas les médecins savent
pas ce qu'il y'a eu conseil génétique
que le couple concerné soit déjà eu un
enfant malade d'une pathologie génétique
soit l'un comme l'autre ont une histoire
de pathologie génétique dans ce qu'on
appellera leur pedigree servir dans leur
famille et donc à partir de là on va
leur proposer à ses 4 % de gens là de
diagnostiquer l'embryon pour savoir en
tout cas celui qu'on va réimplanter s'il
est bien dépourvu de la pathologie pour
donner un enfant qui somme toute aura
toutes les bonnes raisons de s'épanouir
par la suite problème et ça c'est
difficile à entendre et à expliquer le
problème c'est que que ça soit j'allais
dire unités euros par voie naturelle
sous la couette comme disais député j'ai
trouvé la solution assez étonnante que
ça ce sous la couette ou que ça soit
dans une boîte de pétri aller une
fécondation sur deux elie garantie d'un
échec
alors quand ça se passe sous la couette
c'est à ça ça se remarque pas c'était un
petit retard c'est un avortement
spontané très précoce et on sait
pourquoi on sait parce que la pizza en
france et que c'est lié à une anomalie
du nom
pour deux chromosomes donc on est je
n'arrive pas à comprendre ma
collectivité n'arrive pas à comprendre
quel soin médical ou scientifique
pourquoi appartement sur une cellule de
l'embryon on regarde par exemple si le
gène de la mucoviscidose nez ou n'est
pas muté on ne regarde pas en même temps
ce qui ne rajoute aucun manipulation
supplémentaire si le nombre de
chromosomes le duo 22 ce qu'on appelle
les autonomes est bien le bon parce que
sinon on va faire parc où vivre un
parcours à la femme totalement inutile
et qui va être garantie d'un échec alors
que déjà la situation initiale et
complexes alors on va avancer on en
parlera puisque ça va venir en débat
bientôt je vous propose de passer à un
autre gros texte qui va occuper le
parlement jusqu'à noël
il s'agit du budget
[Musique]
le projet de loi de finances pour 2020
arrive à l'assemblée troisième budget du
quinquennat le premier après la crise
des gilets jaunes
objectif mettre en musique les pros
massé annonces du président stéphane des
pierres la priorité du gouvernement
c'est le pouvoir d'achat des français
comme promis par emmanuel macron au
printemps l'impôt sur le revenu va
baisser de 5 milliards
entre la suppression de la taxe
d'habitation et la forte diminution de
l'impôt sur le revenu il y aura au total
9 3 milliards de baisses d'impôts pour
les ménages ce qui est sûr c'est qu'on a
choisi de baisser l'impôt dont use de
quasiment tout le monde
95% des contribuables ça fait à peu près
de mémoire 10 7 millions de foyers
c'est vrai qu'on a concentré la baisse
n'a pour seul revenu sur les 12 millions
de foyers c'est à dire l'essentiel de
ses 17 millions qui sont en dessous la
tranche de 30 % c'est un choix politique
c'est ce qu'on pourrait appeler les
classes populaires et moyennes
et on n'a pas voulu sortir de l'impôt
sur le revenu ce qu'on va peut être une
tentation des gens les mesures d'urgence
prises pendant la crise des gilet jaune
et le ralentissement de la croissance
pèsent sur les finances publiques le
gouvernement réduit donc ses ambitions
en matière de réduction du déficit
public
il atteindra 2 2% du pib et non 2 %
comme prévu initialement
l'exécutif explique que c'est le taux le
plus bas depuis 20 ans pour la france
en fait les ministres jouent la prudence
pour ne pas réveiller la grogne sociale
fait un budget en fonction de priorités
économiques et d'une situation
économique et sociale la situation
économique
c'est le risque de ralentissement marqué
en 2020 et vous tenez compte aussi de
l'environnement social et
l'environnement social je vous apprends
rien c'est une crise sociale majeure
nous avons connu il ya quelques mois qui
nous amène à tenir compte des attentes
des français
ce budget affiche aussi la priorité pour
l'écologie 800 millions d'euros sont
prévus pour la transition écologique
notamment dans les transports
sauf que le gouvernement ne touchera pas
à toutes les niches fiscales
défavorables à l'environnement juste une
question philippe berthet ce que le
quotidien des français aujourd'hui c'est
la priorité notamment la priorité de
bercy il me semble que oui il ya des
moments où on est on est peut-être plus
fier que d'autres de faire partie d'une
majorité je veux ça mouvement démocrate
dans bien sûr la majorité est très
sincèrement même s'il a été publié hier
vous comprenez qu avec la vie des
musiques du moment j'ai pas plus me
pencher très profondément dans dans ce
budget quand je vois moins 9 milliards
d'affiché d'impôt pour les français
quand je vois mois 1,1 milliard de moins
pour les entreprises donc dans une ligne
qui va nous conduire sur cinq ans à
moins 40 milliards d'imposition alors qu
il faut le traduire ça est la traduction
au moins pour déjà si je prends ne
serait-ce que les 12 millions de
français des couches les plus
défavorisées bien ça globalement dès
janvier parce que grâce à la
mensualisation ça va se voir tout de
suite ça va être avec la taxe
d'habitation + 1000 euros de pouvoir
d'achat est ce que nous avons déjà vécu
ça dans ce pays je ne pense pas vous
êtes plutôt donc favorable à ce budget
sur ce point là mais ça ne commence pas
très bien sur les questions budgétaires
puisque la semaine a été marquée aussi
par un couac mardi edouard philippe a
été contraint d'annuler le coup de rabot
prévu par le gouvernement sur les
emplois à domicile pour les personnes
âgées
regardez dans les réactions au sénat du
président du groupe socialiste patrick
kanner et le patron des sénateurs les
républicains bruno retailleau
c'est un couac évidemment mais c'est un
couac qui est très très inquiétant parce
que le gouvernement semble s'acharner
sur nos aînés sur les personnes âgées
rappelez vous on a eu d'abord 25%
d'augmentation de la csg ensuite on a eu
la désindexation des retraites est
désormais on s'attaque notamment à
l'emploi à domicile c'est grave parce
que on a un immense défi qu'elle
vieillissement on a un immense défi
qu'est le maintien à domicile et le
maintien à domicile des personnes âgées
chez elles coûtent beaucoup moins cher
que dans des structures collectives dans
les ehpad ou ou même parfois dans les
hôpitaux quand ça va mal donc
je crois que là vraiment ce couac il
veut dire quelque chose et j'espère que
sur la réforme des retraites on va pas
s'attaquer au pouvoir d'achat des
retraités une situation qui est pour moi
ubuesque à savoir que manifestement
cette mesure était inscrite dans le
marbre du budget qui va nous être
présentés entre quand elle espère un
jour à venir par le gouvernement et d'un
coup de rabot inverse il ya 350 millions
de dépenses fiscales qui disparaissent
aussi vite qu'elles sont apparues
donc moi je suis très inquiet sur cette
méthode de travail
et puis je vais vous dire les personnes
âgées de ce pays nous retraités ont déjà
subi la hausse de la csg sur les
retraites le gel de leur retraite donc
ça ne peut pas être la variable
d'ajustement des mauvais choix
budgétaires du gouvernement
vous entendez un les sénateurs très très
sévère sur ce quoi qu'est ce que vous
vous avez pensé de ce recul du
gouvernement
c'est un retour au pédalage bienvenue ça
quand même permis d'éteindre l'incendié
avant qu'il se propage mais c'était
malvenu
oui c'était mal très mal venue faut pas
dire les choses autrement monsieur moi
j'ai découvert ça comme peut-être tout à
chacun par voie médiatique de mémoire ça
devait être la d'histoire une autre
groupe mardi
je crois que au niveau du mouvement
démocrate on était assez remonté
donc on a exprimé et relayé par notre
président mignola patrick mignola cas
qui s'est fait le relais
c était très contradictoires je pense
que on a eu un épisode csg cat est
suffisamment délicat est mal venu parce
qu'une déjà nous ne devions pas été
suivi dans les recommandations mais
quand même le bronca que ça suscite et
sa majorité a payé et finalement ce que
le voile assez mais c'est ça qui me
plaît mais moi je suis un peu peut-être
parce que c'est ce que je viens de vivre
aussi sur la loi de bioéthique on va
dire ouvrir tout à l'heure mais sur le
leurre l'article 4 c'est que on est dans
une construction ce qui n'a pas toujours
été tout le cas de lucas dans cette
cinquième république où il me semble que
nous parlementaires
eh bien on n'existe plus que d'habitude
et on arrive à faire corriger le tir
donc de 7,7 éléments parfaitement
négatif
j'en tire le positif et je me dis tiens
je viens pas à paris toutes les semaines
uniquement pour faire tapisserie et pour
faire aux boîtes d'enregistrement et
bien philippe berta on va faire un petit
passage quand même par le sénat pour
conclure cette émission le sénat qui
examinait toute cette semaine le projet
de loi anti gaspillage et pour une
économie circulaire
[Musique]
les échanges ont été très tendues dans
l'hémicycle entre la secrétaire d'état
brune poirson et le président de la
commission du développement durable
hervé maurey je vous propose de les
écouter
là c'est purement et simplement
diffamatoires et comme j'ai déjà eu
l'occasion de vous le dire
si on doit parler lobby parlons-en parce
que quand on a demandé au gouvernement
une étude sur la consignes pour
recyclage qu'est-ce qu'on a eu à part
une étude fournie par les producteurs de
bouteilles
et qu'est ce qu'on a reçu ici comme
demande insistante des lobbys et bien on
a surtout reçu des messages de coca cola
nous expliquant combien votre dispositif
était pertinent alors ne parlons pas de
lobby s'il vous plaît et moi ce que
j'aimerais savoir c'est quelle est votre
position réelle par rapport au travail
que nous avons fait en commission parce
qu'encore une fois on peut pas nous
envoyer des fleurs à la tribune et nous
envoyer des cailloux dans les médias je
fais le choix de ne pas vous répondre
parce que vous savez comme moi que vous
m'avez à plusieurs reprises invectives
et dans les médias à plusieurs reprises
et je n'ai monsieur vous savez monsieur
le président vous avez plus que tout
vous même quand priorité absolue et
totale parce que vous êtes un sénateur
depuis très longue date la défense des
collectivités territoriales et je pense
qu'aujourd'hui pour commencer les débats
c'est précisément là dessus que nous
devons nous concentrer et je sais
monsieur le président combien vous avez
à coeur
et combien ensemble vous allez vouloir
diriger les débats en ce sens je n'ai
pas double langage j'ai la naïveté de la
sincérité
philippe berta c'est un texte dont les
objectifs ont complètement consensus à
l'économie circulaire et pourtant on l'a
vu le gouvernement les sénateurs il
était à deux doigts de s'insulter qu'est
ce que ça vous inspire
ça m'inspire que du mal parce que
vraiment c'est pas ma vision de la vie
publique sur un texte en plus vous
l'avez dit qui est vraiment passionnant
parce qu'on va rapprocher enfin des
bonnes raisons environnementales de
notre quotidien et on va on va s'en
empare et on va participer et les me
semble que les sénateurs ont été hantées
force de proposition ils ont fait des
propositions intéressantes moi je suis
on verra quand ça va venir à l'assemblée
parce que pour l'instant
c'est eux qui ont tiré les premiers je
vais dire mais on se calme enfin c'est
pas notre vision de la poésie c'est pas
ma vision de la politique du cas merci
philippe berta d'avoir invité de cette
émission un peu spéciale de par le mcdo
on se retrouve la semaine prochaine avec
un sénateur baba et merci à tous sens
[Musique]
conduire